foreign
year of high school I saved up a bunch
of money to pay cash for my first car
and because I was 17 and a minor at the
time my mom had access to my bank
account and she decided to take that
money to pay off to her debt money for
my car I'm so sorry
[Music]
what's up what's up this is John with
the Dr John delone show
I'm so happy to be talking to you guys
hope you're doing well and hope your
families are healthy hope your son is
out wherever you are or if it's raining
I hope you are curled up with a good
book
probably none of those things are
happening but it's always fun just to
toss out some some sunshine out there
right hey if you want to be on the show
the greatest mental health and marriage
podcast ever if you want to be on the
show give me a buzz
1-844-693-3291-1844-693-3291 or go to
John deloney.com ask and please don't
forget listen
the the number of downloads per month is
in the Millions
and the number of subscriptions is not
hit the Subscribe button please please
please it really helps us out and it
helps out people who have never heard of
the show ever and
um if you think this show is miserable
in torture that you can torture people
you don't like that's fantastic but if
you think it's gonna help other people
um man it's such a gift just hitting the
Subscribe button or the like button or
whatever's the buttons are these days
all right that's enough of that let's go
to Leslie insane Paul what's up Leslie
hi Dr John how are you I'm fantastic how
are you
I'm doing great thank you live life's
going okay
yeah excellent what's up how can I help
so
um something I've been wrestling with
internally is wanting to break
generational curses as a first
generation immigrant but you know
feeling a lot of guilt so I had called
into the Dave Ramsey Show and it was
mostly a financial question my senior
year of high school I saved up a bunch
of money to pay cash for my first car
and because I was 17 and a minor at the
time my mom had access to my bank
account and she decided to take that
money to pay off some of her deck
I'm so sorry I called and George and
Christine are kind of helped me with the
financial aspect but I was wondering if
you could guide me through the emotional
aspect of you know I'm in college right
now I'm studying really hard to get a
good job and like avoid debt but then
there's that emotional part of it
what's your what's your cultural
background
um
okay
set a strongly maternal culture
yeah yeah actually no no it's very
okay okay
um
oh man
here's the thing let's let's this is
hard to do and it's really probably not
the right thing to do but let's take the
cultural aspect you know what you can I
can't just tell you to scoot that over
let me just say this
um
I think in in my Western context taking
somebody's money from them is wrong
across the board
it is in my culture too I mean I was
listening to my siblings my aunts and
uncles most people would agree that this
is wrong I mean
so yeah maybe you should take the
culture well I don't want to do that I
don't I think that's that's been a
problem as though you can just take
culture on and off like a pair of
sunglasses right
um but that that helps me because there
are cultures that
your kids are very much yours and so
what's what's theirs is yours and so it
would be seen as something that in my
house would I would consider stealing
you're a thief you stole from me and in
other cultures it might not be seen that
way so I want to be sensitive to that
but at the same time I want to honor
your request to begin to
create your new life here
um as a first gen immigrant and you get
to begin to
wrestle with how do you hold on to the
Heritage parts of your heritage that you
want to keep and you want to be a part
of your life moving forward how do you
how do you grab onto these this new
Western culture that you're learning and
then really what do you have designed
for your life and it sounds like if I'm
I want to speak into too much but it it
sounds like what you're saying is
I have to grieve the loss of my mother
because she stole from me and I'm done
with that relationship is that fair
well I don't want to be done with the
relationship because I know she adds a
lot of hurt herself but I do think that
it's wrong okay let me stop you right
there
you aren't responsible for her hurt
and her hurt doesn't give Liberty for
her to steal from you
I always always
think parents have a right to be treated
with dignity or and respect even if it's
in a dignified way in a respectful way
saying I'm never going to talk to you
again
okay or saying I the word here is
boundaries you are going to have to
learn how to create boundaries that keep
you safe keep your stuff safe and
sometimes staying safe inside of a
boundary also hurts really bad because
it's lonely and you should have your mom
as your number one fan in your life
right now and your mom took from you
and let me also add this layer
she took your money but I think she took
something bigger from you
I think what she also took from you is
your your supports like you were resting
on her and then suddenly she pulled that
that uh support out from under you does
that make sense
yeah that makes sense and it's almost
like you lost your money and that's
heartbreaking and all that you had plans
for that money but it's almost
heartbreaking in like
it's like you're walking on Sand now
right like you can't get a firm firm
grasp on the ground I don't know tell me
tell me keep talking
yeah so like the financial aspect is one
thing but then it was like the
manipulation and the gaslighting that
ensued like oh
there's a little blamed for it
essentially that's that was like okay
well you know money comes and goes it
can be replaced but the manipulation and
gaslighting and then also like like hey
Leslie Leslie make sure you're talking
into the phone okay
yeah there you go and then also trying
to build my own Financial picture but
then like knowing that I'm responsible
for someone else's at the same time is
very stressful you're not you're 18
years old okay
now here's here's here's the deal if you
make big if you make adult decisions
Sometimes they come with adult
consequences what I mean by that
you get your own account so that your
mom can't take it anymore
which I did okay do you pay your own
tuition
but I mean you're not dependent on her
financially
at all okay
um now you have to decide how much I you
can be around her
emotionally physically financially
before you become somebody that you do
not want to become
you become somebody who is snippy who
has to hide things who can't tell the
truth who whatever because it's not safe
see what I'm saying
yeah I understand and this is going to
be really hard because
you're 18 years old and your mom should
be your number one cheerleader and
instead your mom's leading the charge of
making it difficult for you to find your
footing as you grow into adulthood
yeah have you grieved that have you sat
down and just wept or have you just been
angry
yeah I remember one time I just had a
head upstairs and then she came in my
room it's like oh my gosh why are you
crying and you didn't even tell me
um I can't believe that I'm not the
first person you would run to and I
didn't do anything wrong
um by taking your money I didn't do
anything wrong so I don't understand why
you're crying because that was the
response I got and you know that's
manipulative right
yes I I understand okay and
there's something deeper than the
manipulation you know that that's your
mother severing the relationship and
that hurts
it's really easy to stop at the act that
makes us enraged or scared but beneath
that
this the most core relationship you have
is with your mom
he told you through her actions this
relationship is over now it is something
different
and quite honestly you've probably known
that for a long time is that fair
I guess this type of manipulation and
dishonesty and thievery doesn't just
happen once
well okay okay
so the real question is what are you
gonna do now
and I don't know like obviously I
morally it does not feel right to me to
leave your parents destitute for
retirement but I also understand that my
finances have to come first so I don't
know I guess I'm struggling internally
with finding like the right balance is
it you that's leaving them destitute or
is it your mom choosing to not work and
your dad choosing to not work
are they unable
she does work but she has a bunch of
debt that she's making no effort to pay
off
how is an 18 year old kid going to be
more responsible for her adult mother's
life than her adult Mother
it's
you're not you not only are you not
being invited in to be a part of this
solution um you're being excluded from
this
right you're um
uh it's a very parasitic relationship
starving you can't continue doing that
because but because it's such an easy
job she doesn't want to quit and do
something that yes is more difficult but
like would pay more has she asked you to
come help pay her bills
in fact she's like 45 and she's like I
should be retired right now I shouldn't
have to work
wow
um
Leslie just here's the deal you just got
some hard decisions ahead of you
um I agree with you I would not let my
parents be destitute either
but I'm older I'm in my 40s now I'm not
18. at 18 there's very little you can do
and
um your parents have not asked you hey
how can we make our situation different
they've stolen from you how can we do
you know any insights do you know any
new
tips or tricks or hacks and you could
show them you know Ramsey Solutions
stuff on how to get out of debt or you
could show them my friend Ken Coleman
stuff on how to get a job
um
or you could Point him to this show
about how to improve your relationships
and how to improve your mental health
they don't have any interest in that
and so there comes a moment when
you continuing to give them money is
actually disrespectful because you're
participating in you're accelerating
their demise if you will
you see what I'm saying
so don't participate in their desire to
not be well
thank you
so also I think like first of all she
barely speaks English and can can't read
or write so also I sympathize with her
in that sense like she can't just pick
up the Dave Ramsey total money makers of
course it's hard
like there's like and that's what I'm
saying there's no easy path forward here
and I'm not saying that your mom
um
I mean her path is really challenging
it's very very difficult
very difficult and it's lonely and it's
disconcerting and she's lost her her
culture right
um and she's so into this chaos like I I
get all of that it's all hard
the challenge for you is being very
honest with yourself and choosing
reality
you can't heal that for her
she can take steps and she can invite
you in an invitation is much different
than stealing
a plan is much different is more
different than a than a bailout if you
will
and so my heart is broken for her and
with her I totally I empathize with her
all the way
and
I know that until she decides I want
this to be different
and here's the deal I worked with
immigrant students my whole career
they were some of the you better get out
of their way dude because there was no
stopping them
no stopping them
and so there is I've seen it over and
over and over and over again
people deciding enough is enough I'm
gonna make this different now and I'm
gonna take advantage of every resource
and I know poverty's gnarly and I know
I'm gonna have to do something I don't
want to do which is ask for help and ask
for help and ask for help and ask for
help
and I'm gonna have to lean on my kids
not in an oppressive way but in a can
you help me out kind of way and I've
just seen it over and over Leslie over
and over
and until your mom comes to that or your
dad comes to that on their own
you can't walk around being their parent
s what's funny is that he does very well
you welshly but they keep their finances
totally separate which is which is a
whole nother situation yeah yeah that's
just them choosing to be uh
dysfunctional like in their relationship
and again there's so many layers here
there's a cultural layer there's the
um educational layer there's the you're
my kid layer there's the I didn't do
anything wrong there's so many layers
here
and every time there's there's a bunch
of layers I want to clear the deck
and write down on a piece of paper what
can I control and what I can I not
control
and what I can control
I'm gonna go for I'm gonna go from there
I'm gonna do those things I'm gonna take
care of those things
and you can love your mom and like I
said you can treat her with dignity and
you can treat her with respect
but you can't make her decide that she's
gonna take care of herself
you can't make her decide that she is
going to
um have more self-worth than
well I guess this is just all there is
and that you're going to continue your
letter to take from you into
if you will hold you back and in some
shape form or fashion the greatest gift
you could give them is to go be really
successful in school like you said it's
not even about money your dad's got
money they're just not sure they're just
not sharing it
um holding's a mess here
if you were my friend we were sitting
down having nachos I would tell you
write down a piece of paper control what
I can control and let the rest of the
stuff go and just know when it comes to
family when it comes to culture when it
comes to all this mess
letting those things go hurts and it's
painful and you have to grieve it
but just because it hurts doesn't mean
it's wrong
just because it hurts doesn't mean it's
wrong we'll be right back
I've got a word from our sponsor better
help listen I've been on both ends of
therapy in my life I've gotten it myself
and I've walked people through it and
I've seen the benefits from both sides
when someone owns their past and the
cracks in their armor but here's the
deal Getting to Know Yourself is not a
one-time event acknowledging the stories
that make you who you are can be a
lifelong process and talking through
things with the right sounding board
empowers you to change your future and
be the best version of yourself so if
you're thinking about starting therapy I
recommend better help better help
connect you with a licensed therapist
who can walk with you on that journey of
self-discovery and it's a hundred
percent online and it's designed to be
convenient flexible and work for your
schedule just fill out a quick
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and if it's not the
right fit you can switch therapists at
any time for no additional charge visit
betterhelp.com deloney today to get 10
off your first month that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com
deloney
all right we're back
um
let's just get right into it it's time
for more facts or your friends let's do
it
please God change this music
please
so much good music out there there's too
much they say
please
hey it's back to your friends
everybody's favorite all right
um today we're talking about uh an
article it's it's it's relatively old
um it's a couple years old
uh 2021 by Gary Lewandowski thanks how
you say his last name
um he's a writer for psychology today
which is online
um
uh psychology
magazine I guess these seven Grocery
Stores
um trying to think it's more pop
psychology
um they do have all sorts of articles
but anyway
um Kelly do you you found this
yes I did the 10 most common sources of
conflict in relationships
um so I went through this and
I'm going to kind of do it out of order
and I ended up focusing on a few things
other than those 10 things so study of
2600 married couples from Britain China
Russia turkey and the US found the most
common sources of conflict drum roll
please huge surprise here
not really division of labor inside the
home finances raising children and sex
and women were more likely to report
problems than men
way no way
man this these are our research dollars
hard at work America all right I want to
talk about these five for a minute
before I get to
I'll run through the other stuff but I'm
gonna get to these five
division of labor I have man I'm gonna
get myself in trouble here and that's
fine I feel like there's some truth
telling that needs to happen here
this is often regulated along two
distinct lines
and one is discussed a lot and the other
one isn't and I've never heard it
discussed anywhere other than in quiet
Whispers
with a group of guys playing poker or
just going for walks in the woods
because they don't know why their wives
don't like them so much
here's number one
we talk about this and we've got to talk
about it more
women's roles at home even with the vast
acceleration of women into the workforce
I think this weekend I was seven out of
10 college graduates or women I mean the
the scales have tipped so far the other
way
women are in the workforce they're in
higher education they are
um they're closing the the pay Gap
and women still take on the Lion's Share
of household chores
and yes
I think it's because men don't see this
as quote unquote their job and I know
it's going to get me in trouble but
sometimes women do see it as quote
unquote their job and there's this
disconnect and men go home and they prop
their feet up and they then wonder where
their dinner magically is and they
wonder how these diapers are magically
getting changed that exists the research
does if I'm being honest it says that
Gap is closing but it is still not
close to being closed
and
the other line
is often one partner in a romantic
relationship determines the Benchmark
for household chores what needs to be
done around here
and then criticizes or complains the
others not agreed upon standard
and we don't talk about that enough
that's usually talked in hushed Whispers
for instance on excuse my house for
example because my wife doesn't listen
to this show so it's okay
I could do just fine
with the dishes being done two or three
times a week maybe once a week maybe
once every other week
and for my wife they need to be done
every day
seven days a week
and so there's been conflict over time
in our marriage because she says you
don't help out around here
and I'm looking around suggesting
there's no help needed those dishes will
be fine there's like seven plates and
four cups in the dishwasher I mean in
the sink
nothing's on fire there's more in the
cabinet and for her that is one of the
things that needs to be done before the
day is over and so
I would challenge
the notion I'm not helping around the
house
I would challenge that with this idea
that we have not sat down and said hey
here's what makes you feel whole in this
house here's what makes me feel whole in
this house let's get there and then from
there if I don't do what we agreed upon
now we got a problem
Kelly
you're married am I off here oh no way I
mean that you just a hundred percent
described my marriage of oh no it's
gonna be trouble my husband's saying but
the bathroom's clean it means me saying
but it wasn't wiped down this weekend
and he'll be like but it's clean
and so you go to your your girlfriends
you know hanging out and she's like
Robert never cleans the bathroom I gotta
go clean it and he is staring off into
the stars in the in the front yard in
his underwear just like what am I doing
wrong I don't understand yeah the
neighbors don't like us very much so
maybe that explains why
um but yeah because it's like but to him
it's like fine look at it so the issue
here isn't a reported he's not helping
on the house it's really we haven't set
down and established what does clean
look like and you giving a little bit
and being like okay it doesn't have to
be sandblasted every other Saturday and
him you're like yes every Saturday not
every other thank you very much
and him realizing that just because
there's no dirty underwear on the floor
that doesn't mean clean and I remember
my mom told me there's a difference
between picked up and clean I get that
that's the division of labor
this is the division of labor
conversation okay what we did and just
hire someone
oh gosh don't even get me going there
hey and on the other hand I do want to
call this out guys get off your butts
and help around the house
just help anytime here's an example
anytime you're about to sit down and you
look over and you see your wife not
sitting down you don't sit down yet
don't sit down
I work hard all day shut up don't sit
down
she needs to be shut up don't sit down
before you sit down
ask her
hey is there anything I'm not seeing
anything I can do to help how could I
love you better right now right this
second and she might say sit down and
put your feet up man you've been running
like crazy
she might say it would mean the world to
me if you could just go grab the hamper
out of such and such kid's room
what a gift
so I want every every wife every husband
every couple listening to this this talk
about division of labor I want you all
to sit down and say okay where do you
feel like I don't show up for you and
this is me this I'm not genderizing this
it could be any of you where am I not
showing up for you when it comes to
the division of labor in the household
and for those things that come up like I
do help around like the kitchen oh once
a week well that's uh that's all that
needs to be cleaned okay now we have not
a division of labor issue but a what
does labor look like an Excellence issue
a I feel safe I Feel clean I feel gross
I feel not enough
um whatever that looks like
and it may be that the kitchen needs to
be this clean in case somebody comes
over and they're going to judge you
husband or wife by the cleanliness of
your kitchen standards
and so if it's not up to that that
keeping up with the Joneses someone may
come over and judge me so I'm going to
blame him or blame her for not living up
to this imaginary stand you see how we
get into this weird dance
so all that said
sit on and help each other out the
second one finances
I think money finances is less about
money and more about a couple of things
number one control
whoever controls the money controls the
house
and it can be controlled in one of two
ways the very abusive
with significant correlation to physical
abuse the guy and yes I'm over
genderizing this one you don't spend
money without me you don't go to store
by yourself you don't do any like
there's that kind of control I run the
money around here and that women can run
the money like I I am the person in
charge of the money
I'll give you an allowance
so I hear that or hey let me check with
my wife to see if I can buy that sh man
that means y'all haven't talked so that
there's that kind of control
there's also control I just spend
whatever I want whenever I want I buy
whatever you can't tell me what I can
there's that control too which is
madness
also finances is about worth
in our culture when you ask the question
what is he worth what is she worth we
Define that not by relationships and not
by who she who they're loved and who who
they love and who love them
we answer the question what are you
worth with a number which is a tragedy
it's a cultural tragedy
but that's what we do and if my number
is low it's easy to begin to feel like
not pulling his weight he's not worth
much I'm married to a loser and that
goes both ways you know both genders all
over the place
and
the third one
money is a really good indicator you can
look at how much you make right now and
what your career trajectory is and you
can just push out 30 or 40 years and say
okay this is about what our life's gonna
look like
and most of us don't like to live in
that reality
so money tells you who you are and what
you find valuable how you spend money
and so
couples need to sit down and say hey
where are we going
what do we find valuable together in
this life we've chosen to make together
it never ceases to amaze me as long as I
live
people will create humans together
they'll share DNA but they won't share a
checking account
this my money this is his money this is
her money
I can't think of other than just
outright abuse and infidelity I can't
think of something that's more divisive
in a marriage
if you have to protect your own money
you shouldn't get married
because you're not all in you're mostly
in
and mostly it doesn't work in marriage
all right that could be a whole
conversation real quick raising children
um I want to do it like this or you want
to do it like that or my mom did it like
this or this is how I was read kids are
the parent new parent scorecard it's the
report card for parents in the 21st
century
everyone's got steps and tips and tricks
instead of focusing on your relationship
with each other and focusing on your
relationship with the kids
that's a whole other conversation
but there's something about saying okay
when this kid is 25.
what do we want for this our child
and I would start that conversation I
would number one
I want my kid to want to come home
why do I start there instead of I want
my kid to be successful my kid to be a
Fortune 500 CEO I want my my kid to be
married well but because everything
for a child is rooted in
the attachment relationship with their
parents
everything so whenever I think about my
son or I think about my daughter I I
push up to the age they're 25 and I hope
wherever they are married kids single in
the military a roofer
getting a postdoc at Stanford whatever
I number one first and foremost want
them to know oh dude there's a safe
place I can always go
there's two people that are rooting for
me
no matter what
praising kids about relationship fourth
one is sex you know we talk about this
all the time on this show sex means
everything in our culture all of it all
at once it's the most wild twist of fate
but here we are
um and uh um
I'll I'll blow past that one because we
talked about that a lot here I want to
touch on this because it's important
women are more likely to report problems
than men
as Esther perel is reported as women
have entered the workforce and earned
economic independence divorces have
spiked
because women no longer have to take
abusive bum husbands they can just leave
and
throughout history that has not been
possible
and now you see it happening all over
the world
women are demanding more and I want
everyone to hear this this is good for
everybody
and I love what Terence real says
the world of relationships has changed
radically it's exploded
women have been lied to that they're all
they need
you can do this all by yourself now now
that you are economically independent
you need nobody
their careers and Independence will
complete them and save them this isn't
true this is bearing itself out in the
mental health literature and Men
just want to go back to the way things
used to be if we can just get these
roles back to where they used to be
then everything will be fine this is
foolish and stupid it's also not going
to happen
what has to happen is a total rethinking
of marriage and relationships and
attachment and connection this is why I
do this show is to paint a new picture
of what life can look like when two
people get on the same page and say
let's ride or die and let's do this
thing right and we don't have a we don't
have a road map because this isn't how
our parents did it it's not how their
parents did it before them
Terence real says women are unhappy in
their marriages because they want men to
be more related
more relatable than most men know how to
be and men are unhappy in their
marriages because their women seem so
unhappy with them
I think that's so powerful
women want a co-earner and a
co-um parent razor and a CO
partner and a and a somebody to share
their dreams with us someone to talk
with and someone to be romantic with and
most men don't have all those skills
that's all the other skills
and men just want to know why their
wives don't like them
why don't you like me
and I don't know how to ask that
question so I covered up with beer and
football games and loudness and whatever
other thing I decide I'm gonna crank out
into the world
so let's create a world where men can
say hey I feel this thing
and I'm gonna go do the next right thing
and women can say I feel this thing and
then I'm gonna go do the next right
thing and we're gonna do the next right
thing together
and a quick Buzz through these things
the 10 sources of conflict Partners
condescending
possessive jealous or dependent
neglecting rejecting unreliable abusive
Unfaithful and considerate
um physically self-absorbed a great sign
of immaturity there Moody emotionally
unstable you spray your feelings all
over the place sexually withholding or
rejecting
quick to sexualize others you're always
talking about how hot everybody else is
some of you are listening to this and
you're like I don't know what to do
here's a great place to start
foreign if you're like oh crap that's me
that's me that's me great place to start
get a babysitter
take your significant other out
male or female I don't care
and start the conversation like this
I'm sorry
I made you a project
I'm aging my dad I was trying to be your
mom
I thought complaining and nagging or
avoiding and not participating
was the way I could get through life and
I don't want that anymore
I want you and I to build something
bigger and greater and I'm going first
I'm sorry
I don't know how we get to where we're
going from here but I'm committed to
ride if you are let's do something
different let's create a life worth
living let's create a life where we
laugh a lot and it's not very anxious
and it is a life of Joy because it's
gonna be hard so let's agree to
[Music]
do the hard stuff together and to create
a life it's not anxious and that's fun
while we can
start there
start there few few conversations are
made worse by starting with the words
I'm sorry
[Music]
let's minimize conflict if we can
we all need a little less conflict we'll
be right back
hey good folks John deloney here I feel
like I fell through a glitch in The
Matrix this is my job I get to have this
show do this show walk alongside each
one of you as a career this is what I do
and I have a blast doing it and me and
the team were so thankful for all of you
for being a part of our show whether
you're one of the original 17 or you're
one of the millions that's come since
then we are so grateful for you and we
want to put together the best possible
show that we can so if you're one of The
Originals or if you're brand new we want
your feedback tell us what you love
about the show what you hate about the
show would you like to see more of would
you like to hear more of and what you
want us to never do again you can email
us at askjohn ramseysolutions.com that's
ask John
ramseysolutions.com with your feedback
thank you for being such an important
part of the show rock on
all right let's go back to my hometown
H-Town and talk to Alex hey what's up
Alex
Dr Delaney how are you I'm partying man
how about you
better than I deserved excellent I'm not
partying at all actually I'm at work
what are you doing man
not much
very cool how can I help
um okay well
um um just in short um I have a history
of being very rageful
um if a person is trying to make me mad
or angry and they say the right thing
I can go from very happy to full-on
bridge mode very quickly uh this has
resulted in a wedge between my parents
and myself it resulted in me pushing
away my ex-girlfriend whom I still love
with all my heart and I'm curious as to
how I can get rid of this because it's
turning me into something that I don't
recognize
I mean it sounds like emotional
regulation issues how long have you been
rageful
my mom says it started when I had brain
surgery
lead with that dude lead with that
so I had brain surgery and then I became
uh had some emotional regulations what
kind of brain surgery did you have
I have had epilepsy for 17 years
okay so you've got brain lesions so they
go in and take out a chunk of your brain
somewhere what'd they do they attempted
so it was a week and a half of brain
mapping so that they cut into your brain
or your skull not about the brain and
they wait for your seizures and then
track them and Trace them
and try to try to determine where
exactly the stages are coming from yep
where were yours coming from
they determined there was it was far too
close to Broca's area that they cut into
that area
um and missed I would not I would not be
able to speak for the rest of my life
worst case scenario oh so that was down
your frontal lobe
yeah nothing nothing they said they made
my choice they said we would need
parental consensus I'm saying it's down
there I think that's that area right
behind your ear right oh yes yes sir
okay
um and so it was close it was far enough
back that they didn't want to dig in
there
okay all right
um
okay
I'm not I'm not entirely certain if
since I I didn't suffer like a a massive
like massive brain damage or a head
injury I'm not sure if there's a
correlation between change of behavior
and just like an invasive surgery such
as that
um but that's when my my parents said
that
um my my anger started to increase
so I've got two trains of thought here
okay and I want to just say outright I'm
not a neuroscientist by any stretch of
the imagination not even close Okay
um my first thought is have you heard of
the Phineas gauge story
they're doing the the bolt went like
through his eye and out yeah it shot
through his funnels yeah he was a
railroad guy in the 1800s and he was
packing powder and it exploded and he
shot it like a missile through his brain
and
um but he lived
and the story goes before this happened
he was a fun-loving fun guy and the part
of the brain that it severed that it
shot through
um had to do with emotional regulation
part of his brain and his frontal lobe
and
he the people around him said he became
a radically different person he couldn't
keep done a job and then 12 years later
he ended up with some pretty significant
seizures and he passed away but he
became really they called him the father
of Neuroscience because it started this
idea like oh there's certain parts of
your brain that house certain activities
and certain
um where's memory and where is motor
functioning and where is thought and
where is laughter and where's fear all
that became came from
oh he lived he's just a totally
different guy now and
so that's my first thought either you've
got a brain lesion somewhere or when
they were in there messing around
um something happened
that's number one
the other side of it is
you may have heard me say this if you
ever listened to show but anger I
believe
is to quote Rage Against the Machine
anger anger is a gift
it points us towards things that are not
as they should be
or as we see them not as they should be
and I view rage as caged up anger with
nowhere to go and it becomes explosive
and I can imagine if I'm you
now again I'm rattling off top of my
head here okay I if I'm you and I've
been suffering from seizures for so long
how were they Grandma seizures
they're called partial complex
only a size half of my brain and do you
know when they're coming or they just
hit you out of the blue
and what's the
um do you get catatonic do you do you
have a full-on seizure on the ground
like what what what is your physical
um expression of these seizures
so if I were to have one um just like
you know in front of you face to face
versus someone who is not familiar with
what a seizure looks like
they would think that I'm kind of just
like tearing them out and just you know
not paying attention to what they're
saying I might just stand up and like
walk around aimlessly uh take something
out put it down
um
I've had one grand mal seizure in my
life okay so when you have these
seizures you feel them coming on they
come so frustrating
it's like you're not in control of your
body right
exactly they have in at least twice a
day okay
and you go to all this brain mapping all
this surgery
they get all this stuff done
and they tell you sorry man we can't
help you
if that's me
I would be angry that I got this brain
I'm looking at all these kids in my
grade and they've all got brains that
are different
that seem to be functioning and they're
drinking them and smoking them away but
I got one that chooses to shower me with
electricity a couple of times a day and
I I
ah
and then the doctors say hey we get
anything for you
and that just puts a lid on that anger
and in my world that's rage
and so what I'm telling you is I don't
know if this is
um physiological or if it's
psychological
what I think is important is you've
identified this as a problem is that
fair
absolutely yes sir
is it something that you have determined
you are unable to help
you finger yes your rage
you're lashing out at people is what I'm
asking you yes yes for example my
parents
um I regret it immensely
but do you do you if you and I were just
sitting across a table looking at each
other would you tell me she said a thing
and I was
physically unable to stop what happened
next
or if you Plumb the depths of Alex would
you say no I was just so mad and
frustrated I just snapped but I could
have not
it's hard because it's a little bit of
both
[Music]
um
once I have started yelling at someone
that's when I do I'm not unable to stop
that's fine so what what how far up the
river can you move
I so for example
the other the other night my mom said uh
it was it was my fault that
um
my girlfriends and I broke up and she
was right she was just telling me things
that were true that I did not want to
hear and I just kind of had to bite my
tongue and let's stop right there let's
stop right there
what if when your mom starts telling you
something you don't want to hear
and you feel your body as though you
feel a seizure coming on you start to
feel your body tense up
and it starts to become a powder keg
what if you said Mom I love you
the things you're saying are right
I need to distance myself from this
conversation for a minute
um let's Circle back at another time
and that other time maybe when you've
had more rest the other time maybe when
you're not stressed out the other time
maybe before work instead after work any
number of things
okay but when I say how far up River can
you get there's a moment when you're
going over the waterfall it's too late
man that thing's we've gotta we gotta
that boat's going over the waterfall and
we got to see what happens at the end of
that cycle right yeah and I don't know
enough about it I wouldn't even know
what to do if I looked at your brain
scans or anything like that so I don't
know I don't know what the surgeons did
I don't know any of that of your
psychological State I know any of that
stuff
but based on what you're telling me I
think the adventure is not trying to
hold back a boat going over the
waterfall
I think the adventure is
knowing uh oh I just found myself on
this highway again and this isn't a good
Highway for me
so I'm gonna go ahead and just stop the
car and I'm gonna get out and walk if I
need to but I'm not going to go down
that Highway
and what what I'm guessing you're gonna
find is some significant increases in
self-control that you didn't otherwise
have before
does that make am I making sense
yes is that scary frustrating because
here's the deal all of us have to do
that on a daily basis
your your project ahead of you is just
going to be harder than mine
and I think we just have to own that
reality
do what's accepting the way things are
currently
um is is very uh hard to do it is
it is what's the alternative
um
um go to war with reality
yeah
I'm kind of done going to war Alex
I look around to see a pile of bodies in
my life and I'm kind of done with that
so I'm going to make peace with it
I'm going to make peace with it
but um I I heard you you talked about
speaking about you know how children
should be brought up your whole like you
know they should they should want to
come home
I want my parents to think that I I want
to come home I don't want them to think
that I hate them okay
have you here number one you can't
control what your parents think
and I hate that for you but you can't
foreign
thing is
is no matter what's happening
behaviorally your parents have some sort
of guilt over the way your brain works
the way parents are
they're wondering what they mean my
brain works Yep they're wondering what
they ate to give you this genetic
issue
or what they
how what part of their DNA contributed
to the wiring system you know like
parents will go to the they will find a
way to blame themselves dude
and so it may be
you do what I just said in that last
segment but you're doing it for parents
you flip it around how old are you
23 sir 23.
man
can you imagine scrounging the money up
and taking your parents out to a cheap
breakfast
at Cracker Barrel there in Houston and
saying Hey I want y'all to know I love
you so much I'm so grateful for
everything you've done
and I'm gonna get to the bottom of this
thing and I'm gonna ask you to number
one
um stay with me don't give up on me
because I'm not giving up on y'all and
I'm not giving up on Alex
can you imagine that conversation
that would be amazing
can you do that
yeah would you do that here's it would
you do that for you because you're
carrying so much weight my brother
and here's the other piece of that
letting him know
I I'm gonna work on just use that
analogy I just gave you I'm gonna work
on trying to reclaim my emotional
regulation and that means I'm gonna have
to get way up River
and sometimes I may put my hand up and
say
I need to back off a step away from this
conversation
um if you can give me a half hour I
would really appreciate it and
to tell them don't take this as a sign
of disrespect I'm not being ugly I just
feel my body heading down a river that
has a waterfall at the end of it I don't
want to do that
I'm trying to choose a different way
and over time your body hopefully will
def will settle in and if it doesn't it
may never ma'am
you've got some neurological
architecture challenges that the rest of
us don't have
and so again instead of going to war
with reality just knowing I need to
avoid these kind of confrontations
because I get to a place where I can't
come back
and I would strongly recommend that you
get with the neuropsychologist and see
if there's some sort of
um
some sort of exercises you can do to
begin to practice emotional regulation
the brain's got a magical way of
drawing from other parts of the brain
that don't normally do activities to
engage that part of your brain to pick
up the slack
okay have you already done that have you
met with a neuropsychologist
with a psychologist and a
neuropsychologist okay there's some
there's psychologists that are trained
to look at your brain and to say okay
here's the particular challenges in this
particular part of your brain they're
gonna they're gonna they're going to
express themselves behaviorally in this
way and so let's work here
I want to give you some tasks that are
just unreasonable because of your brand
architecture right
yeah sure I don't want you to beat
yourself up for things that you can't
help I also don't want you to avoid
things that you could help you just
didn't have a guy to take you through
the jungle
okay
but beyond all this stuff before I let
you go
don't give up on Alex man
I'm serious I can hear you I can hear
you're just freaking tired
I'm so tired
probably tired of the seizures tired of
hurting people that you love tired of
being alone tired of feeling alone
all I've ever thought about is myself
I took my family for granted
I heard people that I loved
and I I just I don't want to be that
person anymore okay
two things number one don't be
number two
cut yourself some slack dude you've been
trying to not die your whole life
is that fair yes
a couple of times a day every day for
your life you are struck by lightning
no matter where you were in the bathroom
with friends talking to a cute girl
wherever you happen to be
you always knew at some point I'm gonna
get hit and I don't know when and I
don't know where and I don't know how
it's gonna look to the person I'm
talking to
and that made you short and that made
you frustrated and that made you hard to
be around sometimes big whoopty freaking
do
see it
if a little 12 year old boy came up to
you and was trying to apologize because
somebody said I'm gonna punch you in the
face twice today you're never gonna know
what's coming
and you walked up and that kid snapped
at you like hey
and they said oh my gosh I'm so sorry
sir I'm so sorry sir you would get down
on both knees and say little boy
someone told you they were gonna hit you
it's okay it's okay and you'd hug that
boy tightly wouldn't you
absolutely yes
hug Alex for me because you're not right
here in front of me
foreign
thank you
don't give up
what I imagine for you in the future is
you've got an extraordinary story to
tell
little kids in your exact same situation
that one day you become a really
pathfinding neuroscientist or you become
a great local counselor or you just
become a great accountant
that's got a temper
and that sometimes abruptly walks away
from conversations
[Music]
but that people look too because you're
honest and you really understand what it
feels like to not be at home in your own
body
and so you're able to sit with people
through all sorts of hell that they've
walked through
what I'm saying is the world needs you
[Music]
don't don't Rob the world of the gifts
you're gonna give them
get the help you need my man
so grateful for you we'll be right back
hey what's up now that my new book own
your past change your futures out in the
wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
all right we wrap up today's show Kelly
mcfill quick curveball
um this song is one of my favorite songs
in the whole world by
one of my top two or three bands ever
ever
um
songs called The Ballad Of Love and Hate
by the great Avett Brothers and I'm
gonna fast forward to the end of the
song here
it's just a
love song that they wrote
between love and hate the song ends up
like this
hate gets home lucky to still be alive
and he screams over the sidewalk and
into the drive and the clock in the
kitchen says 255 and the clock in the
kitchen is slow
and love has been waiting patient and
kind just wanting a phone call or some
kind of sign that the one that she cares
for who's out of his mind will make it
back safe to her arms
and hate stumbles forward and leans in
the door weary head hung down eyes to
the floor he says love I'm sorry and she
says what for I'm yours and that's it
whatever
I should not have been gone for so long
I'm yours and that's it forever in your
mind and that's it
forever
we'll see you soon
[Music]